Kristen's not hanging around radio row
much later than usual they said to us we
got an interview set at 3:30 p.m.
Eastern on Thursday we said we're not
staying they said it's Russell Wilson
we're staying around I guess do it doing
good man you there man oh man I
appreciate you guys unbelievable year
seriously I mean every week I know you
don't you block probably all the noise
out but we we wax poetically about you
you're amazing yeah preciate man it's a
lot of hard work you know and I like
great players around you and it can do
some cool things so that was great year
you know we wish you were being playing
right here though this weekend we had a
chance you know so right hopefully can
get back to it next year yeah it's just
amazing you guys are in a division now
where you thought you had to worry about
the Rams now you got to worry about the
49ers and here's caliber in the
Cardinals I mean this is tough as
division and football yeah I would agree
with that
you know in terms of the defensive lines
and the defenses and then you factor in
the quarterbacks and the guys that can
make plays and their offenses and the
coaches and stuff too
it's a great division of playing it
really is you know you made a comment
recently to I got you know in the media
about how you need more superstars in
your team what what do you mean by that
well I think that every every year you
look to win free agency I think that's
important every year that hasn't changed
no matter what the circumstances are I
think that as we go into you know trying
to win a championship I think as we go
throughout the season and go go
throughout the next several years I
think that's that's the key part is is
is finding those playmakers that
continue to be on your team for years
and years to come I think we obviously
got got like you know DK Metcalf I hope
we can get clowny back open right Bobby
Wagner is one of those guys we got so
many great players on our team and I
think two free HD is gonna be really key
for us but that's no surprise we're not
trying to like you just saying you need
one or two guys you always want you
always want that that that's that
special special special player to find a
way to make a crazy play right and we
can add to that was guys like Tyler and
DK and all that it'll be great for us
well you got a taste of it with Jadeveon
Clowney you get to see up close how
disruptive he can be on a regular basis
and I'm assuming you'd much rather have
him chasing the other quarterbacks in
the division then possibly chasing you
yes you definitely don't want him facing
today yeah I had to deal with that when
he played for the Houston Texans and he
came to Seattle he
all over the field but he's been a great
addition to our team
just what he's brought to to our locker
room when he's brought to the field you
know that really the reality is you
gotta take two three guys sometimes to
go block him you know and so how you can
get to coorporate even even in our game
when we play at the 49ers the first time
that crazy matchup both of them are
crazy but he is all over the field oh my
god so you know he's a special player a
special guy you specifically like I just
like your mindset okay I know you got
the month the most incredible self
believe I've ever seen but when you're
going to a game like literally tell me
what's in your mind okay you're down by
four points and you're running out on
the field for the last Drive of the
football game like are you set what are
you saying to yourself and your brain
like take us in to Russell Wilson's like
what are you saying are you calming
yourself down are you telling your every
bike you're going this is a big moment
what what what what makes you click like
tick there well for me I think the
language that you that you say to
yourself you know in between your ears
and what you say to your teammates is
really really critical to being
successful right so what they hear and
what I what I tell myself is is the most
important part of it I think one of the
things is that I always try to tell
myself like got it right where you want
them you know it's got him right where
they want and I think the reality is is
that I want them to know it to the other
team I'm talking right right you know
and so when I step on the field I want
them to feel that presence I want them
to know okay
oh you know and and I always like being
up I'd rather be up I hear that but if
we're down the game's not over
yeah all right and I'm gonna go there
because division around fourth and 11
three minutes left you guys have the
ball he's hey Russell Wilson
they got Aaron Rodgers and I'm thinking
all right Russell's got this fourth in
11 he's gonna run at 12 yards he's gonna
throw it 15 yards they're gonna keep
driving they're gonna win this game and
I see the punt team coming ups like what
in the hell is going on here in your
mind how do you process that when coach
says all right we're gonna punt and
we're gonna try to get the ball back you
want the ball in your hands don't you
well give me of course I mean I think we
definitely with the ball in your hands
but you know the reality is is that we
had three amazing drives back-to-back
you know bang bang bang and they knew we
were coming back in that game anyway I
was I was joking with za'darius and
Devante a little bit this weekend you
had the Pro Bowl
and they were talking about that a
little bit but in that situation you
know it's you know we've got to find a
way to make a stop you know and
unfortunately didn't and you know
there's two ways to go about it you know
and I you know if they called my name I
would have been ready we've found a way
to make it get the first down but you
know I I think it's from a from a
strategy standpoint we were we were back
we weren't and I backed up we were on
the minus side of the 50 if we don't get
it there that they probably win the game
just naturally by kicking a field goal
right it's over so you know I think that
unfortunately didn't we're able to stop
them you know if we was if we were able
to stop them there on third and seven or
whatever it was and get the ball back
you know the games probably over so you
know hopefully the plan was to win it
either way and you know it's a flip of
the coin I guess yeah well they had a
guy on their team that's got belief like
you and their team believes in to it's
it's it's unbelievable what is it about
the Seahawks and like why do you got to
drive me crazy every Sunday with like oh
we fell behind in her and it's a big
game and now Russell's got to go crazy
backyard football magic man you know
what what is it why can't we find that
rhythm earlier in the game at times um I
think we figured that that's what we got
to figure out you know as we going
throughout them you know this offseason
and we were trying to capture that
earlier on because I think we do it
really well I mean we've always been
really good to minute amounts we've
always been really good
and those into the half those those
those not always hurry up situations but
those those up-tempo moments reality is
this I think the defense gets tired
verse there the second thing is is that
you know you know I really know kind of
what I want to you know get get after
them how we want to get after them
especially those moments and and guys
just make plays in those moments I think
the freedom of just going after and just
score as many points you know that's
kind of what the Chiefs do be honest
with you they they they do a really good
job Andy Reid and mahomes they do a
grill a good job of getting up to the
ball playing with their playmakers and
find a way to make plays and you know
they score more points than everybody
else Danny that's the name of the game
is you can't score one more point than
they do right and there's different ways
to go about it listen the reality is
we've won a lot of football games over
here I know but we all we all very high
standard but we also I think there's
also on the expectation of being here
not just sitting here in this seat next
to you guys unfortunately
the big plan here the serious yeah but
but being on the big banner and and
winning at all so yeah you know we're
gonna we're gonna try to figure that out
and see if we can get back here quickly
we got two versions of Russell Wilson
that we see we see the Russell Wilson
who takes his drop goes through his
progressions makes the throw and then
there's the guy who just explodes out of
the pocket yeah on that second that
second act where everything is just
chaos which version is better well like
I'm both like I'm both I think I think
both of them are winning formulas I
think you know dropping back you know
staying in the pocket we've been on to
make a lot of cost a lot of havoc in
that sense and and be able to you know
play action it too as well and then hand
the ball off and run it to and when we
can and and then also the the creativity
can't do it all the time
you know it's one of those things that
you want to be able to do it's one of
those special traits that we have you
know as a team and we you don't want to
use it too much because then it's it's
not as special right right so you want
to be able to use it in timely moments
when it when when when things aren't
going well or something happens and the
guy gets covered or whatever it is okay
let's go create let's go create you know
the next play and the next play is is
you know causes havoc for the defense
you all right you're the man on the
field like you're the man off the field
for this for me okay this is the this is
the ultimate OG let's figure out Jimmy
Fallon kicking off the contract talk
last year like that was amazing to me
like I in again I'm in talk radio and we
do a talk show but I was like holy cow
like Jimmy Fallon just helped to start
the negotiations between Russell Wilson
and the Seattle Seahawks like that was
just I don't know it was just a moment
that jumped out to me I talked about it
last year it's like was Jimmy Fallon
like into like the salary cap here now I
mean he knew it was coming though he
asked the question I'm coming the
highest a guy in the NFL and within a
month or two you were you yeah it's
almost like a jump started the
conversation or got like the national
media to be more aware of it well I
think for for Coach Carroll and I and
Josh signer and Mark my agent we had we
had already talked about it as soon as
the first game was over they had been
talking to us about you know potentially
making it so you do yeah the
conversation was already going it wasn't
anything new
gotcha
to us we've kind of been in the process
and the journey of it all and I worked
out the place that I wanted to be and
yeah and it's been a blessing for sure
yeah how much attention do you pay to
where the other guys are because they've
been other contract since and nobody's
caught you yet at 35 million but we know
Patrick Holmes is coming at some point
you got to Shawn Watson out there da
Quan says how much are you watching to
see which of those guys is gonna be able
to to get past you with or without the
help of Jimmy Flint you want those guys
to continue to do what they do great you
know cuz along the way it continues to
push the press the game you know it it
helps every player not just the
quarterbacks but every player to be
honest with you and you know those guys
are they deserve it you know guys like
Patrick my Holmes is he's fierce and
then Super Bowl doing some special
things he's got playmakers around on me
he's got all the throws and all the
place that he can man he's got great you
know coach and great mind in Andy Reid
and they say he's making it happen you
know and so and I'm not gonna be
surprised when Patrick gets the nice
payday
well alright first off I wanna have we
want to ask you about the game but I
want to hear about what you're pitching
cuz every year we see you you got like
the coolest new like sport I'll be like
hey this is Russell Wilson and posting
this day he's the man he gave this to me
he's trying hard to get you know it's
been pretty cool i've been with bose for
a long time now several years and you
know ever since I was a little kid I
always listen to music it was kind of
the thing that always kind of put my dad
and I together you know we all obviously
sports and all that sure he used to
coach me in everything else but we used
to jam out to music in the car I never
going to Peyton Manning camp when I was
a little kid and just listening to
oldies and being in the car with him in
Louisiana what songs give it
oh man we listened to everything we
listened to to O'Jays we listened to
Earth Wind and Fire we listened to the
patient's Teddy Pendergrass and we've
listened to everything so we're you know
I grew up old-school but you know not my
house now I'm constantly listening music
obstacles Ciara sure and me and so the
kids are constantly dancing playing me
so we got music always playing around
the house and but then also you know the
headphones they in the bose
noise-canceling 700 s the 700 are key
for me because I like going out in the
field and just kind of can't say on all
the noise when I get out in the field
it's it's it's it's gonna be peace mode
you know it's it's right where I want to
be and and so these help me ignore the
noise
promoting beast mode you want beast mode
to come back again this year that'll be
cool why not I mean you score four
touchdowns the playoffs alight it was a
good time alright so you got to play
Kansas City last year so you got a
little feel for them I know they're not
you can't really give the great scouting
report but we're gonna put you on the
spot okay all right I mean tell us about
the 49ers and then give us your gut
feeling on who you think's gonna pull
this game out well obviously Bo's to
come off the edge that's that's key can
they slow him down
I think Armstead up front can they
slowed him down those two guys call it
happy and they can run the ball like a
few times I know I know the Chiefs are
gonna run in a bunch yeah when they do
can they get positive runs out the RPO
game's gonna be critical in this game
because they do a really good job of the
Chiefs - yes the other one you know the
run pass option and if they can make
that happen then the scrambles you know
connect can they that's where the game's
gonna come down today because yeah if
mahomes can scramble and get outside the
pocket and make some plays on the field
with guys like Tyree he's got so many
weapons and he's got he's got guys are
world-class speed world-class hands he's
got Kelsey as well gets open does a
great job getting open so that
creativity of what mahomes can do in all
the playmakers he has around him in
addition to the scheming of what Andy
Reid's gonna do right it's really gonna
come down to Ken akin the 49 or slowed
that down and the scrambling ability of
what mahomes can do it's gonna be a
great matchup it is you know I what's
your gut side that you think they can
slow him down like was that the best D
lineman
D line you played this year yeah I would
say across the board yeah they got the
first four guys and they got another
three fright right I know so I would say
across the board yes obviously guys like
Aaron Donald play back yeah I would say
so for sure and you know it really helps
you know across the board on defense and
what they can do
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with the Chiefs
though because I'm Holmes yeah you know
but it's if you me a tough guy
it's always hard to go questioning now I
think the really good Sherm still who's
the guy that my home's needs to be
worried about though when he starts to
run which one of those defenders is
gonna close on him and maybe get him
down on like elbow so I would say is the
guy that can catch up and get to him D
Ford's back - so he can really run - as
well right but I would say Bosa and then
the guy that you really gotta you know
watch for when you're throwing it deep
down the field is obviously Sherman
those late Late Late balls he
it really has a really good idea of
depth perception and figuring out where
the ball is down the field and those
hills come his hands yeah so he really
eats like a centerfielder he really
tracks that ball really well as you saw
in the last game and then FC
championship game when he picked off
Rodgers I mean he he kind of baited him
and he went after and picked him off at
the end of the game to end the game so
that's what he does best
what's the all-time scoreboard Seattle
Seahawks practiced 2012 through 2017
Wilson versus Sherman who's leading in
that oh man I'll go over there too often
you know I try to stay away from them as
much as possible I'm not crazy but you
know it's always been good battles I'm
not gonna try to pick a fight right you
know but no sure sure
sure make me better you know I'll say
that a legion of boom always made me
better cuz when I came in as a rookie it
was one of those things that was the
best defense literally and maybe
arguably in football in history
disrespect in the secondary bow down and
so for me it was it was a challenge
every day looks like I was playing a
championship game every day and those
guys made me better ensure most was
always great in that sense of being a
talk to me about different things that I
was doing or he was doing I I could talk
to him about different things so I got a
lot respect for how he plays the game
yeah but also it's been great watching
the first eight years of your career and
I know you've said it you told me a year
and a half ago you've said it more
recently 45 still the goal 45 yeah I'm
gonna make the 45 well we get to enjoy
14 more years I'm looking forward to it
like on three go Hawks let's do it one
two three go hawk
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports